german police have arrested a british
citizen suspected of spying for russia
the man identified as david s was
employed at the british embassy here in
berlin prosecutors say that on at least
one occasion he passed on documents to a
member of the russian intelligence
services in exchange for cash he will be
brought before a judge
later today
well our correspondent julia saudelli is
following this story for us julia what
more do you know about this alleged
spying case
well the suspect was arrested yesterday
in potsdam with it which is just outside
of berlin he has a british citizen as we
heard and he is a local hire at the
british embassy here in berlin that
means he is not a member of the british
diplomatic corps he is suspected of
being a member or of working with
actually uh the
foreign
intelligence service since november 2020
at the latest and uh prosecutors believe
that he has handed over documents that
he obtained while carrying out his
duties to a member of the russian
intelligence service and uh that that
this has happened at least once that
does not exclude that this may have
happened more often he received cash in
exchange for the documents it's unclear
at what amount of cash he he received
and investigators have searched his
apartment and his workplace in an
investigation that is being carrying out
jointly by germany and britain
okay so this sounds like something that
involves the german government the
british government and potentially the
russian government any reactions from
these governments so far
the german government is clearly not
really happy with what has gone down
here a spokesperson for the foreign
ministry
has said that uh germany cannot accept
that spying on a very close ally occurs
on german soil the ministry also said
that they are
taking the spying allegations very
seriously and they'll continue to follow
the case very closely the british
government has confirmed that the
arrested was contracted to work for the
british government but has declined to
give any further comment because of the
ongoing investigation
juliet thank you very much for now that
was our political correspondent julia
saudelli
you